all right thank you nate car lovers
start your engines and head to mesquite
this weekend for 13th annual mesquite
motor mania
car show all right who better to check
something like this out than jc
fernandez
he has a preview hey jc i tell you what
guys it's going to be car heaven and
mesquite this weekend with over 900
classics on display
including this one right here and i want
you to meet this is christian with
mesquite motor mania car show tell
everybody
the back story the history of the car
show absolutely we're we're 13 years ago
we start off with just 200 cars
this weekend we're gonna invite over 900
cars up in mesquite nevada
if you're a car fan you've got to be up
there we're going to have every make and
model
uh so if you're a car fan here you see
any type of car you want to see what are
we looking at right here this is a
beautiful 1956 continental this is a
this is a museum showpiece car right
here
this was built before the lincoln
continental even existed
uh through the ford motor company
fantastic car one of a kind right here
it is gorgeous did we mention the cost
to go up here this weekend what's the
cost
uh absolutely free republic it's the
best it's the best one
here we go with the 2007 shelby super
snake
we have 725 horsepower under the hood
here and i think this is one of the best
parts about the car show you get to see
all these beautiful cars
get to see what's under the hood burnout
competitions roaring engines
open header cruise through mesquite
friday and saturday ton of stuff to do
so it's not just 900 amazing cars on
display there's something for everybody
for the entire family because it's open
to all ages
i want to circle down here and talk
about this gmc but also
in mesquite this weekend are the hotel
rooms available absolutely we still have
rooms though but they are going fast go
to casablanca resort dot com to grab
your room for this weekend
this is a great gmc truck this is going
to show you absolutely what we have a
full variety of vehicles from your
classics
muscle cars customs to your rat rods we
got
every kind of car underneath the son of
mesquite this weekend all right
everybody
turn to our right take a look at this
one give me the back story on this one
christian i've been checking this out as
soon as i pulled in today yeah this is a
1937
chevy race car this thing's been racing
for almost 100 years
and you can fire this thing up right now
and hit the track and you're gonna do
pretty darn good too
now someone's watching right now and
they want to put their car on display
are you still taking i guess
applications to bring cars yes you can
register
your car on site just come down to the
kaspanka resort and
you can register your car and be
involved in the show and the other cool
thing is when you bring the family up
free to the public to attend you can
vote for your favorite car and it counts
towards the
the winners and all the prize men that
we have now the weather the wind is
going to die down the weather is going
to be amazing this weekend
i think as far as pandemic we're in a
great spot but there'll be safety
protocols in play
absolutely we've we've submitted our
safety plan to the state it has been
approved and we'll be following all the
current cdc guidelines because of mass
and social things so you have a safe and
a great time
and plenty of cars to look at all
weekend long lance come on down here to
this corvette we have down here the
final car
now uh what are the prizes this weekend
that people can win that show their cars
absolutely fifteen thousand dollars in
cash and prizes are available
uh for all the cars this is a great
corvette you can't have a car show
without a corvette
and you're going to get up there you can
see the stingrays all the way to the
brand new corvettes
so really if you're a car fan i can't
stress this enough get to the casablanca
resort in mesquite nevada
you're going to see 900 cars it's gonna
be fantastic it's going to be a great
weekend you guys made a mistake you left
the keys in it
all right i'm gonna send it back to you
guys in the studio i'm just gonna take
it and gas it up don't worry your car's
in in great in great hands you guys
mesquite motor mania car show send it
back to you guys in the studio you'll
know what he's thinking letting jc take
off in that all right mesquite motor
mania friday
may 21st through may 23rd excuse me
mesquite nevada just call 877-438-2929
or visit casablanca
resort dot com